in belgium 23 people are going on trial
today in the city of bruges in
connection with the deaths of 39
vietnamese migrants in 2019 the migrants
were found dead in the back of a truck
near london several men including the
drivers have already been jailed in the
uk the trial targets the larger human
trafficking network that was smuggling
people people seeking a better life in
britain
for more let's bring in dw correspondent
terry schulz she's live in bruges for us
terry what are the charges being heard
today at the court
hello yes well in the courthouse behind
me prosecutors are describing the
belgian leg of an alleged trafficking
network stretching from vietnam to the
uk
they say that these 39 victims were
gathered in a safe house in brussels
then transported by car to france where
they were loaded into this refrigerated
container with no incoming oxygen that
container was then brought nearby where
i am now to the port of zebra get and
sent across to the uk of course the 39
people inside would not make it now the
23 defendants range from taxi drivers to
the accused ringleader of 45 year old
vietnamese man and i should say i just
spoke with his attorney who says his
client is innocent but he does face a
significant prison term
now these tragic deaths of the
vietnamese migrants happened in october
2019. let's have a look back at how this
tragedy unfolded
their journey ended here an industrial
estate east of london
in october 2019 british police
discovered the lifeless bodies of 39
vietnamese migrants in this trailer
truck
two of the victims were just 15 years
old
they'd each paid thousands to people
smugglers to cross from belgium to the
uk in hopes of starting a better life
instead packed inside a sealed container
for at least 12 hours they suffocated to
death
in the uk
seven men have already been given
lengthy prison sentences
the defendants on trial in bruges are
accused of operating a human trafficking
ring between belgium and the uk
the majority are themselves a vietnamese
descent
terri it's really horrible to imagine
the suffering that these people went
through what more can you tell us about
the victims
that's right we know from evidence at
the scene that as they realized they
were running out of air they tried to
poke holes in this container but it was
absolutely impenetrable and and it
wasn't possible at all to either do that
or alert anyone to open the container
and get them some air so as they realize
they were not going to survive the the
victims started sending messages to
their loved ones we know that one man
told his wife and children that that he
was sorry he wouldn't be able to take
care of them anymore but that he simply
couldn't breathe
one 26 year old woman sent a message
telling her mother that she loved her
and that she was sorry that her trip
abroad had failed but that she was now
dying now some of these family members
are due to share their stories with the
court
tough stuff to to hear there terry how
will this case proceed
the trial now in the in the building
behind me is due to take two days and
again with 23 defendants the the charges
range uh vastly from from you know
simply being a taxi driver who
transported some of these people to this
45 year old man who is really seen by
prosecutors as the man at the center of
the belgian leg of this this trafficking
network again his lawyer says he's
innocent but he does face up to 20 years
in prison and we should also point out
that investigations in the uk and in
vietnam have returned heavy prison
sentences for those determined to have
been involved so i would imagine that
his defense team is feeling a little bit
unsettled at the moment
terry thank you dw's terry schultz for
us in bruges
you